sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
verehrten kolleginnen kollegen
fährt der kollege merz ich habe ihnen
eben sehr genau zugehört
ich will ihnen ich will ihn einst
antworten und das schätzen sie unser
land nicht unterschätzen sie nicht die
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
in schweren zeiten wächst unser land
über sich selbst hinaus wir haben eine
gute tradition uns unter zu haken wenn
es schwierig wird bund länder und
kommunen politik zivilgesellschaft
arbeitgeber und betriebsräte unternehmen
und gewerkschaften der spaltung
herbeiredet der gefährde den
zusammenhalt in diesem land und das ist
jetzt der falsche
und außerdem ist es so dass wir in einer
situation sind in der die union die
meisten probleme schon als gelöst
vorgefunden hat bevor sie sie überhaupt
erörtert hat ich will das mal ganz klar
sagen bereits im dezember habe ich die
zuständigen minister gefragt was ist
eigentlich wenn wir schwierigkeiten
kriegen mit lieferungen aus russland und
wir haben uns bis zum kriegsausbruch
darauf sorgfältig vorbereitet um dann in
dieser situation entscheidung zu treffen
die weitreichend sind und die
weitreichend auch jetzt schon umgesetzt
worden sind etwas auf dass niemand
anders sich vorbereitet hat
wir haben zum beispiel entschieden und
mit dieser bedrohung klarzukommen dass
wir den norddeutschen küsten
flüssiggasterminals bauen dass wir die
pipelines baum die dazu notwendig sind
damit ihr unabhängig von russland gas
nach deutschland importieren können wir
haben die kapazitäten aus den
niederlanden aus belgien jetzt aus
frankreich erweitert weil wir ein
problem mit acht und uns vorbereitet
haben über das sie damals noch nicht
einmal gesprochen haben
und in einem tempo zudem keine cdu
geführte regierung in diesem land je
fähig gewesen ist werden wir es schaffen
im januar gern die ersten dieser
terminals ihren betrieb aufnehmen das
ist eine gemeinschaftsleistung in
deutschland
und während cdu geführt der minister es
überhaupt kein problem fahren
ministerien ist überhaupt kein problem
fanden dass die speicher für gas in
diesem land leer waren im letzten jahr
haben wir dafür gesorgt dass sich das
ändert mit gesetzen und regelungen die
wir auf den weg gebracht haben
sie hatten noch nicht mehr in der
opposition ist der fertiggebracht das
eigene versäumnisse als problemen der
neuen regierung unterzuschieben wir
hatten es schon gelöst bevor sie
überhaupt mitbekommen haben dass er
einst war das ist die wahrheit sprechen
und während wir mit den speichern für
gas in deutschland so unverantwortlich
vorgegangen wie das die zu vorher
verantwortlichen der vorher
verantwortliche minister und die
regierung gehabt haben dann würde ich
ihnen ausdrücklich sagen hätten wir
jetzt nicht 85% speicherkapazität
sondern quasi nichts so wie im letzten
jahr das ist der unterschied zwischen
der union und den verteidiger das land
hier
sie haben noch immer gefordert dass wir
dafür sorgen sollen dass die speicher
voll sind und da haben wir die gesetze
schon gemacht sie könnten auch mal sagen
dass sie das eine beeindruckende
leistung finden haben hat
und da gibt es noch ein thema auf das
sie gar nicht gekommen sind über das sie
nie geredet haben wo sie nichts
gefordert haben als es darauf angekommen
wäre wir haben gesetze auf den weg
gebracht die dafür sorgen dass
kohlekraftwerke in diesem land in dem
betrieb gehen können klasse genutzt
werden können dass sie nicht
abgeschaltet werden alles das haben wir
auf den weg gebracht das war eine
notwendige leistung mit großer
geschwindigkeit und großem tempo die wir
hier auf den weg gebracht haben
und sogar solche fragen wie die die sie
ihren nebenbei angesprochen sind links
dabei gelöst zu werden wie zum beispiel
das natürlich die kohlekraftwerke
loslegen können auch wenn sie nicht
genügend gelagert haben und auch die
tatsache ist die biomasse anlagen dass
die solaranlagen alle aus alles an kraft
zeigen können was sie brauchen das haben
wir gesetzlich alles vorbereitet sie
brauchen nur noch zugucken wie das
geschieht es ist schon erledigt bevor
sie es ausgesprochen haben
und wir haben ein gesetz gemacht fuel
switch die gesetzlichen regelungen dafür
geschaffen dass überall in deutschland
betrieben unternehmen entscheidung
treffen können dass sie nicht auf gas
zurückgreifen müssen sondern andere
anlagen betreiben können damit wir
gemeinsam gas sparen und durch diesen
winter kommen auch das haben diese schon
gemacht sie haben das noch nicht mal
gefordert
ich weiß es ist für sie sehr
enttäuschend weil sie sich so sehr auf
das thema der kernenergie konzentriert
haben aber das was wir jetzt vorbereiten
ist dass die möglichkeit besteht dass
wir die kernkraft anlagen die
atomanlagen im süden deutschlands
betreiben können damit es niemals an
strom lange in deutschland gibt auch
wenn das in diesem winter im januar
februar und märz notwendig ist das ist
vorbereitet und das ist die grundlage
dafür dass das ganze was sie sich schon
vor zwei wochen als rhetorisches konzept
erlegt import überlegt haben hier heute
gescheitert ist
sie reden einfach am thema und an den
problemen dieses landes vorbei und das
ist wirklich ein ganz ganz großes
problem und wenn andere die probleme
lösen die sie noch nicht mal erkannt
haben dann reden sie auch noch drum rum
im übrigen ist das jetzt eine situation
in der wir anders als vor einem jahr
weil wir soviel eingespeichert haben
weil wir all diese vorkehrungen
getroffen haben weil wir all diese
entscheidung getroffen haben in einer
situation sind in der gesang kommt
können wir kommen wohl durch trotz aller
anspannung durch diesen winter mit den
vorbereitungen die wir gemacht haben das
hätte niemand vor drei monaten vor vier
monaten vor fünf monaten vor am beginn
des jahres sagen können und weil wir so
früh angefangen haben als noch gar nicht
ein so großes problem problembewusstsein
in deutschland da war darum sind wir
jetzt in der lage dass wir tapfer und
mutig in diesem winter hinein gehen
können dass unser land das überstehen
wird das ist die sache die wir gemacht
haben
insofern sind sie also schief gewickelt
wenn ich das mal so sagen dass sie haben
einfach an dem thema vorbei geredet dass
unser land wirklich und hat und wir sind
jetzt dabei die nächsten dinge zu tun
die notwendig sind damit die bürgerinnen
und bürger und unsere wirtschaft durch
diese situation kommen wir haben bereits
zwei entlastungs paket beschlossen und
jetzt kommt das dritte weil wir ganz
konkret gucken was zu tun ist wie wir es
schaffen können dass die bürgerinnen und
bürger dass die unternehmen dieses
landes dass der mittelstand die großen
unternehmen die möglichkeiten haben die
sie brauchen damit sie weiter
produzieren können damit die
arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben damit man
sich das leben leisten kann und ich
finde es ist richtig dass wir das getan
haben wir haben zwei erste paket von
knapp 30 milliarden euro bereits
beschlossen jetzt kommt 1 noch einmal
dazu dass knapp 65 milliarden euro
umfasst alles zusammen eine ziemlich
große summe und das dient dazu dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger durch diese zeit
kommen dass die unternehmen kommen durch
die zeit kommen und dass die
arbeitsplätze gesichert werden you never
walk alone das ist das motto dieser
regierung
ich bin sicher unser land wird über sich
heraus wachsen wir werden zusammenhalten
wir werden die herausforderung bestehen
vor denen wir uns jetzt befinden und wir
werden die probleme lösen die wir
miteinander haben weil wir niemanden
alleine lassen mit seinen
herausforderungen und dazu dienen auch
all die entscheidung die wir getroffen
haben zb die entscheidung zu sagen dass
jetzt wo in diesem monat die
energiepreis prämie gezahlt wird das
alles als möglichkeit bei den
arbeitnehmenden arbeitnehmern ankommt
haben wir auch entschieden dass es auch
für rentnerinnen und rentner und
studenten gelten soll das ist eine
entlastung in einer schwierigen zeit wo
alles teurer wird richtig dass wir das
tun erklärte
wir machen eine bürgergeld reform die
dafür sorgt dass diejenigen die sehr
wenig geld haben auch durch diese zeit
kommen können dass sie unterstützt
werden aber vor allem sorgen wir dafür
dass teil diejenigen die diesem land
arbeiten oder als renten um rentner
einmal gearbeitet haben all die
unterstützung bekommen die sie brauchen
damit sie das finanzieren können was an
teuren lebenshaltungskosten bei ihnen
ankommt und das ist geschehen mit den
dingen die ich schon genannt habe aber
zum beispiel auch mit der größten
wohngeldreform seit der einführung des
wohngelds in diesem land zwei millionen
berechtigte stadt 700.000 das wird
unglaublich viele familien in diesem
land besser stellen arbeitnehmern und
arbeitnehmern mit geringen einkommen und
rentnern renter eine richtige eine
notwendige entscheidung
zum beispiel indem wir dafür sorgen dass
familien unterstützt werden das
kindergeld wird erhöht die schritte die
für das nächste und das übernächste jahr
anfallen machen ziehen wir zusammen
machen das sind ein schritt mit 18 euro
wir sorgen dafür dass der kinderzuschlag
verbessert wird da geht es für manche
familien um ein paar hundert euro im
jahr die sie mehr zur verfügung haben
eine richtige eine notwendige
entscheidung in dieser zeit
wir sorgen dafür dass diejenigen die
wenig verdienen und den wir mit
steuerentlastungen wenig helfen können
eine entlastung bekommen indem wir die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge für die sie
zahlen müssen absenken und dafür sorgen
dass bis zum einem einkommen von 2000
euro die progressionszone bei den
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen fortgesetzt
wird das sind über 1,3 milliarden euro
netto entlastung für diejenigen die am
wenigsten in diesem land verdienen und
von steuersenkung sonst nichts hätten
nicht zu vergessen dass gerade jetzt
wenn das stattfindet zum ersten oktober
der mindestlohn auf 12 euro angehoben
wird in einer solchen zeit eine dringend
notwendige entscheidung für die wir uns
lange eingesetzt haben meine damen und
herren
und wir entlasten die bürgerinnen und
bürger in dem wir steuersenkung
beschließen in großem umfang in dem wir
auf die inflation reagieren und
dementsprechend das flächendeckend
organisieren mit der anhebung des
freibetrages mit den steuer senken damit
verbunden sind übrigens verknüpft mit
lauter maßnahmen die wir jetzt auf den
weg bringen oder schon auf den weg
gebracht haben wie zb dass die
rentenbeiträge abgezogen werden können
vom steuereinkommen voller höhe das sind
die beiden nächsten jahre zusammen fünf
milliarden euro entlastung für
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmer eine
richtige entscheidung und eine
notwendige entscheidung
und wir haben dafür gesorgt dass die
arbeitnehmerpauschale angehoben wird das
wird weiter im nächsten jahr gelten dass
die pendlerpauschale angehoben ist auch
das sind dinge die alle da zusammen
beitragen dass wir eine möglichkeit
haben durch diese zeit zu kommen und für
uns ist auch wichtig dass wir uns nicht
nur auf uns alleine beschränken ich habe
schon vor der sommerpause gesprochen in
der konzertierten aktion mit
unternehmensvertretern mit
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber mit den
gewerkschaften mit der wissenschaft der
bundesbank über die frage was wir machen
können wenn wir uns unterhalten und
deshalb ist die konzertierte aktion eine
notwendige antwort des zusammenhalts auf
diese krise und wir werden deren
entscheidungen und die aktivitäten der
unternehmen unterstützen indem wir sagen
wenn jetzt wegen dieser preissteigerung
der höheren energiekosten die
sozialpartner die gewerkschaften und die
arbeitgeber vereinbaren das ist höhere
sonderzahlungen gibt dann werden wir bis
zu 3000 euro steuer- und abgabenfrei
ermöglichen das ist eine konkrete
botschaft des zusammenhalts in
deutschland und eine botschaft betrat
partnerschaft
sie sehen also wir haben sehr viel
gemacht um die drängenden probleme
vieler bürgerinnen und bürger in den
griff zu bekommen und wir werden das
auch weiter tun weil das notwendig ist
die maßnahmen die wir gemacht haben
haben wir auch große erfahrung mit sich
gebracht viele haben hier sehr skeptisch
diskutiert ich erinnere mich und an
einige äußerungen aus der union bin ich
das richtig erinnern dass wir das neun
euro ticket einführen und ich sage
ausdrücklich das war eine große sache
die skeptiker hatten nicht recht und
deshalb wird es eine fortsetzung geben
für eine lösung die das möglich macht
bundesweit abonnierbare digital buchbare
tickets zu haben die zu einem
vertretbaren tarif überall in
deutschland die nutzung des nahverkehrs
möglich machen eine gute entscheidung
aus der krise gewachsen aber für viel
viel längere zeit sinnvoll
was dann natürlich dazu kommt ist dass
wir die herausforderung bewältigen
müssen die mit den steigenden
energiekosten verbunden sind wir haben
also als sie noch nicht daran gedacht
hatten schon das problem gelöst wie
sichern wir die energieversorgung
deutschlands
was nicht möglich gewesen ist denn die
cdu/csu ist die partei die die komplette
verantwortung dafür hat dass deutschland
ausstiegs entscheidung getroffen hat aus
der kohle und aus der atomenergie aber
die niemals die kraft hatte in
irgendetwas einzusteigen sie warnt
unfähig den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien weiter schüren sie haben ab der
kämpfe geführt gegen jede einzelne
windkraftanlage und jeder ab der kampf
der letzten jahre schadet unserem land
noch heute das vorsieht
dafür haben sie auch immer sehr
freizügig gemogelt die letzte mogelei
war vor der letzten bundestagswahl
unions geführtes wirtschaftsministerium
mit absicht wurde die wahrheit dass wir
bis zum ende dieses jahrzehnt ein
anstieg der stromproduktion von 600
terawatt auf 800 terawatt brauchen
verschwiegen und als der bundestag in
die sommerpause kam da wurde es
veröffentlicht das ist und
verantwortliche cdu politik die uns die
jetzige situation gebracht
hallo herr merz
hören sie genau zu
als ich vorgeschlagen hat denn der
bundesregierung wir sollten doch
flüssiggas cremans bauen an den
norddeutschen küsten wir sollten doch
flüssiggas terminals an den deutschen
küsten bauen und wir dazu einen brief
entwickelt hatten hat ein mitglied der
bundesregierung vermutlich cdu dass dem
spiegel gesteckt damit sich alle darüber
aufregen dass wir das tun hätten wir es
man getan will ich ausdrücklich dazu
sagen dann müssen wir jetzt nicht mit
diesem tempo rast machen
und eine partei die bis heute fast jede
windkraftanlage persönlich bekämpft hat
überhaupt nichts zu tun mit der frage
wie lösen wir die energieversorgung
probleme der zukunft das ist die
wahrheit wir aber haben in diesem jahr
schon mehrere gesetze auf den weg
gebracht und werden noch weitere auf den
weg fragen die dazu führen dass wir in
dem notwendigen schnellen tempo den
ausbau von erneuerbaren energien
zustande kriegen offshore wind onshore
wind solaranlagen ein starkes
leistungsfähiges netz und
selbstverständlich alles was dazu gehört
und wir hatten auch schon ein paar
probleme weniger wenn es nicht der
heroische kampf der csu in bayern
gewesen wäre dafür zu sorgen dass noch
nicht alle übertragungsnetz leitungen in
den süden deutschlands errichtet worden
sind das war das was sie gemacht haben
dafür tragen sie die verantwortung
es war unverantwortlich das zu tun und
es ist gut dass sie in der opposition
sind damit wir die industrielle
modernisierung unseres landes hinkriegen
damit wir wettbewerbsfähig bleiben und
uns nicht mehr vor den problemen dieses
landes drücken
ja wir müssen unabhängig werden von den
gast importen aus russland und das
werden wir in großer geschwindigkeit tun
in wilhelmshaven in stade in wulsbüttel
in lubmin werden neue terminals
entstehen wir haben an den
westeuropäischen kosten mit unseren
freunden gesprochen in den niederlanden
in belgien dass sie die terminals
ausbauen und die leitungskapazität mit
frankreich das das erste mal gas zu uns
liefern wird wir haben probleme gelöst
da hatten sie noch gar nicht mitgekriegt
dass sie überhaupt existieren und das
ist das was wir jetzt zustande gebracht
haben mit den terminals im norden und
mit denen man in deutsch besten
europäischen küsten werden wir eine
sichere energieversorgung für
deutschland gewährleisten
was aber natürlich auch dazu gehört und
das will ich dazu sagen ist dass wir
jetzt mit denen nachdem wir die
versorgungssicherheit zum großen thema
gemacht haben auch das problem mit den
preisen in den griff nehmen und deshalb
ist es richtig dass wir sagen wir werden
das mag design auf dem strommarkt
verändern wir werden nicht zulassen dass
die hohen preise die für strom aus
gaskraftwerken heutige zeit lernen dazu
führen dass es extra große profite
gipfel jemand das mit bildkraft mit
wasserkraft mit solarenergie der das
macht mit braunkohle und steinkohle oder
nukleare energie sondern wir werden
diese zusätzlichen gewinne abschöpfen um
die bürgerinnen und bürger zu entlasten
mit einer strompreis bremse das ist die
richtige antwort und wir haben sie
gegeben
unser könig werden wir uns mit der frage
der gaspreise auseinandersetzen müssen
und der hohen kohlepreise und ölpreise
die ja alle davon auch mit berührt sind
wir haben uns darum gekümmert dass das
möglich ist wir sorgen jetzt dafür dass
wir zusammen mit europa diskutieren wie
kriegen wir das thema in griff denn
anders als beim strommarkt gibt es ja
darum dass wir importieren aus ländern
die die preise anderswo bestimmt aber
wir müssen trotzdem hinkriegen dass sich
das ändert das erste was wir hinkriegen
müssen ist das wenn wir das geschafft
haben worum wir uns jetzt im eiltempo
kümmern und sich vorher niemand
gekümmert hat nämlich dass wir jeder
zeit gas aus aller welt importieren
können mit den ganzen terminals über die
ich eben gesprochen hat dass wir den
weltmarktpreis nur bezahlen müssen und
nicht die höheren preise die durch diese
fehlenden import strukturen heute
aufgerufen werden aber wenn wir das
geschafft haben dann geht es jetzt auch
darum dass wir den weg beschreiten wie
wir diese preise nach unten kriegen das
werden wir mit unseren freunden in
europa und mit allen hier in deutschland
erörtern denn das ist eine sache die wir
nicht auf sich beruhen lassen die preise
für die energielieferung müssen runter
die bürgerinnen und bürger müssen die
preise auch bezahlen können und wir
werden dafür sorgen
wir erleben eine zeitenwende ich habe
das hier im deutschen bundestag gesagt
das ist der russische angriffskrieg auf
die ukraine der die europäische
friedens- und sicherheitsrat nung
zertrümmert hat der unverändert eine
riesige große bedrohung ist für frieden
und sicherheit in europa denn das war ja
die verständigung der letzten jahrzehnte
dass das nicht passiert dass man mit
gewalt grenzen verschiebt und etwas
anderes ist es nicht als imperialismus
was der russische präsident versucht
sich nicht mich einfach teile des
nachbar territoriums oder das ganze
anzueignen und man darf ihn auch nicht
missverstehen da hat das ja alles
öffentlich gesagt in aufsätzen
geschrieben es gibt überhaupt nichts an
der frage zu deutschland was seine
absicht ist deshalb unterstützen wir die
ukraine mit unseren verbündeten wir tun
es schon sehr lange und wir tun es sehr
effektiv auch mit den notwendigen
schweren waffen mit artillerie mit
möglichkeiten zur luftverteidigung und
all dem was wir auf den weg gebracht
haben das sind die modernsten waffen die
exakt jetzt in dem gefecht im osten der
ukraine gebraucht werden wir werden das
auch weiter tun das ist unsere
verpflichtung so lange wie es notwendig
ist
und es ist sehr umfangreich was wir
getan haben aber eins unterscheidet uns
von ihnen ganz offensichtlich sie haben
es heute bekannt wir werden keine
alleingänge machen wir werden keine
deutschen alleingänge machen das wäre
ein schwerer schwerer
unverantwortlicher fehler und ich sage
ausdrücklich an die union gerichtet wer
für alleingänge plädiert sollte dieses
land nicht regieren
und was wir tun was wir tun ist
eingebettet in die gemeinsamen handlung
mit unseren verbündeten insbesondere den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und wer
nicht verstehen will wer genau begreifen
will was die regierung leitet der
braucht nur den aufsatz von präsident
biden in der new york times durch lesen
wo er exakt das erzählt hat was ich
ihnen hier auch sagen erstens wir werden
als verbündete handeln wir werden keine
entscheidung treffen die dazu führen
dass der krieg den russland
verbrecherischer weise gegen die ukraine
führt zu einer eskalation eines krieges
führt zwischen nato und russland aber
wir werden das notwendige tun und genau
entlang dieser linie denkt eingebettet
in das bündnis in mit unseren freunden
in aller welt unterstützen wir die
ukraine und werden es so lange machen
wie es notwendig ist
das sind ernste zeiten es sind ernste
zeiten in denen der zusammenhalt in der
gesellschaft von allergrößter bedeutung
ist und deshalb sind es auch zeiten in
denen sich immer wieder beweisen muss zu
was wir miteinander fähig sind ich bin
überzeugt wir sind ein land das diesen
zusammenhalt auch hat das in der lage
ist die schwierige zeit zu bewältigen in
der wir uns jetzt befinden und es auch
in der lage ist den weg in die zukunft
zu beschreiten das haben wir gemacht mit
weitreichenden entscheidungen in diesem
jahr weit reichende entscheidung als sie
in den letzten jahrzehnten über alle
zeit hinweg verteilt worden sind in
einem einzigen jahr das ist die aufgabe
der regierung und das werden wir auch
weiter zu tun
[Applaus]